alors le coup de coeur cette semaine du
ciné cette fin aussi 17 c'est le dernier
film évidemment des frères dardenne la
fille inconnue toujours du très bon
cinéma production franco belge avec la
magnifique actrice adèle haenel je vous
dévoile pas l'histoire c'est une
histoire pour une fois on va dire un
petit peu critique qui louche un petit
os du côté du du polar du thriller
social on va dire comme souvent chez les
frères dardenne
mais c'est un film très très bien conçu
qu'il faut alors absolument découvrir
dans nos salles cette semaine
sheehy victoire koussa sûreté tout et
j'ai senti tout coeur qui va être deux
fois plus vite que juste avant quand
j'avais pris ton fond je pense que c'est
parce que tu venais de voir l'image de
la fille ça veut quelqu'un qui la
suivaient ceux qui sont quelqu'un qui
prétend avoir vu juste je vous accuse de
rien j'arrive pas à me faire à l'idée
qu'on va l'enterrer sans connaître son
nom et puis le deuxième coup de coeur on
va dire pour aller rapidement
c'est évidemment cap captain fantastic
avec viggo mortensen qui a été présenté
à cannes cette année
c'est l'histoire d'un père qui élève ses
fils on va dire en dehors de la société
et qui va être obligé de revenir dans la
société ça pose un certain nombre de
problèmes
cette fois ci c'est votre baptême du feu
mettez votre entraînement à profit
ils sont des hot-dogs figues du col du
poison en bouteille
vient en tout cas je suis très heureuse
que notre famille sérieux nous c'est que
du bio et du local les poulets tu les as
tu es avec moi une hache ou un couteau
euh je suis allé à la boucherie j'ai
acheté les poulets et sur une île était
déjà mort
c'est un très beau film une histoire
familiale à drame familial on va dire
donc à découvrir sur nos écrans cette
semaine